now one day after House Democrats cinema
subpoena Rudy Giuliani is Giuliani is
mounting his offense sorry he just hired
Watergate era attorney John sale and now
is considering future steps now Rudy
welcome back
finish your thought but what are those
what are those steps we'll get back to
that time let's talk about this because
this is kind of like the future and I
had a couple of talks with civil rights
lawyers and constitutional lawyer today
and here's what they're recommending
that we should bring a lawsuit on behalf
of the president and several the people
in administration maybe even myself as a
lawyer against the members of Congress
individually for violating
constitutional rights violating civil
rights they're doing extraordinary
things for example they're violating
there they are interesting with the
president exercising his rights on the
article to President United States is to
conduct the farm policy United States
they're calling foreign leaders they're
going to foreign capitals senator Murphy
went and threatened the president of
Ukraine with no Democratic support if
you cooperate you go to court against
the house they wouldn't get
congressional immunity immunity unless
they set it on the House floor right so
anything that they see I found I show no
really that's it's that I found a really
good case today about assuming a
conspiracy a conspiracy to violate civil
rights if it isn't except for what they
say on the floor yeah there isn't they
are Azzam liable for that as anything
else how about the congressmen who
threatened to arrest the Attorney
General hello let's remind everyone in
light of what you just Southside of
Congress he did what Maxine Waters too
is saying can we play that guy's what
she said I don't know yes I think we owe
it's just a tweet sorry she basically
said that the president should be put in
solitary because a congressman is a
congressman who said on May 8th 2019
that the Attorney General should be
arrested that was outside of Congress
Schiff said he he'll say Trump says
so-and-so's guilty of treason I mean
there's a tweet yeah those axes Gord
here everyone's gonna be doing everybody
are you worried that you shouldn't have
mentioned those texts last week on the
show
on our show because now they know you
have and so then they subpoenaed you or
do you think they were to subpoenaed you
anything here I'm saying like I'm glad
you showed us the text they would have
just attended me have any more text I
like this what did what you do good many
more oh I also have video recordings and
I have interview notes which I made in
pursuance of my role as his defense
attorney so if this is an
attorney-client privilege there's no
such thing as an attorney-client
privilege well also sue them for trying
to violate the attorney-client privilege
we can also sue them for doing things
like obstructing of justice I mean going
and writing letters to Italy and to
other countries that have evidence of
criminality concerning of a setup and a
frame-up is obstructing a criminal
investigation
Browdy one of the things that it's a
better theory than mowers it's it's
novel but we've never seen Congress do
anything like this in Turkey we just
said this is unprecedent this will be a
civil case in which we can take
discovery also will sue shift for
they'll have to lawyer up
you're saying you're telling the
Democrats if you're doing this to the
country our economy we have trade our
foreign policy lawyer up I think we have
to we have to raise their violation of
constitutional civil rights this is
worse than McCarthy how about a totally
illicit impeachment proceeding this one
illicit do you consider this tantamount
what they've done to foreign
interference in an election they've
accused Trump wrongly of that well they
actually do think so they did this what
the angle was that's what I was a Vista
Vierra knew the election what I was
investigating Ukraine which there's
plenty of evidences of is the only
interference in this election by a
foreign government out directly is
Ukraine have to be actors you had a Brit
you had an Aussie you had a Maltese you
had a Pekin and we had fun we had at
least two named Ukrainians who have been
found guilty a new Ukrainian court of
interfering on behalf of Hillary yet the
liberal media Rudy and this is part of
what the president's up against let's
face it he's up against a media that
refuses aggressively in curious about
hunter Biden and Joe Biden what they say
is oh this is alright rings conspiracy
this is Rudy Giuliani
can we go back to my lawsuit I want to
give you another example of what we can
do with this lawsuit he's unbelievable
one other thing with a lawsuit let's
suppose just suppose that this whole
thing with the witch which I mean they
yeah what will they call him witch
hunter well no no it's election
interference no they've got the guy who
put the complaint out and the anonymous
a whistleblower I know I keep thinking
which I'm sorry I don't have to demean
him at all he may be telling the truth
might be a shape but he may be lying
yeah okay suppose there was a conspiracy
to develop that with people like members
of Congress that wouldn't be immune
that'd be a conspiracy device I'm saying
the suppose there could be let me give
you evidence okay somebody conspired to
deprive them of the right of
confrontation and the right to call
witnesses the whole purpose of not
getting a vote you realize that the
whole purpose they're not getting a vote
on impeachment is have they gotten a
vote on impeachment that Republicans
would have the right to subpoena
witnesses they're depriving him of basic
rights so your deliberate deprivation
tactic you you are discussing a legal
tactic which I find interesting
it is novel but we're in unchartered
territory but have you ever seen a
constitutional rights and civil rights
pretty this is sue ijen coming you have
to hit their lawyer let's throw out
there trying to get they're trying to
get rid of his government lawyer yeah
Barr and its private lawyer me and you
know why they want to get rid of us
because we're effective do you think how
about how about putting out a demand to
silence me I think that happens and well
that was to set you off they just wanted
to set you off into a frenzy it wasn't
you don't think you were just playing
around there or do you think they're
really threatened oh I have I have some
evidence that a few people have agreed
to do that
oh I can't tell you yet I'm still doing
my discovery Rudi they want to say that
this is a this is a conspiracy theory
about hunter Biden there's no evidence
or it's been largely if not total is
dreadlocked
that's what they say John Solomon's
reporting they always the sale that's
been debunked it's been walked back
except it's totally untrue
no one's debunked it well I want the
media focus they are covering up for the
Democrats because they are more corrupt
than anyone realizes they are covering
up serious crimes that were committed
against the United States by the Biden
family in taking millions and multi
millions of dollars and putting the
United States in a very compromised
position means everybody in the Ukraine
knew that that money was going to buy
Joe Biden and everybody in China knows
that they weren't investing in that
stupid private equity fund with white
profit with with whitey bulger he loves
sang whitey bulger with whitey Bulger's
yes you know all right here's the chime
I want to tell you what you're up
against when you go to Capitol Hill
because I can tell you exactly what
they're gonna say because you're I know
and I want you to do a preview of what
they're gonna do if you decide to
testify at all the use of Giuliani as an
emissary to a foreign government is not
unprecedented but is unusual Woodrow
Wilson Franklin Roosevelt had private
emissaries involved in global peace
talks
I think what's worrying though is that
Giuliani wasn't tasked with carrying out
secret negotiations to advance the
interest of the country but he was
effectively acting as an arm of trumps
reelection campaign that's that is two
things
first of all as there's a private allure
secondly it assumes that it's not in the
interest of the country to dig up
massive corruption by one of the highest
office holes that we are representing
it's not an emptyness re-election
campaign or working for him as a private
eye I heard about this two years before
the election where Joe Biden wasn't even
a candidate he hadn't announced and it
was absolutely necessary in order for me
to defend them they have decided it's
not against the interest the United
States I gotta uncover Joe Biden's
multi-rotor will have you back and I
can't wait to find out what happens with
that appearance before the hell